hello everyone and yes I know what
you're gonna say I said no more alpha
zero games but I decided I couldn't
finish the series without showing you
how alpha zero destroys the French
defense and those of you who have
followed my streams know I really hate
the French defense I always lose against
it even though when I was younger I was
very successful against the French
defense I guess you know you have to
sacrifice some more pawns in the opening
to get an edge against the French
defense and on a side note while
everyone was busy you know watching a
chess game is played by alpha zero Allan
masks artificial intelligence and
managed to defeat a professional dota
players so dota 2 players so what do you
think is a greater accomplishment alpha
zero crushing stockfish or Allan masks
artificial intelligence crushing dota 2
players but ok that being said let's
let's see this game how does one crush
the French defense d4 it starts with d4
but it will transpose into the French
key 6e four and now d5 we've transposed
into the French Knight to c3 Knight to
f6 and now he 5-9 it's variation Knight
F to be 7f 4 now c5 and Knight to f3 and
in this position the move I most often
you know see is something like Knight to
c6 and this is probably what I would
play in this position but stockfish goes
for C chapters on d4 I don't prefer
moves like this I go by the old to take
is a mistake but ok a C capture son
before and night the b5 by alpha zero
Bishop to b4 check bishop to d2 and
Bishop Bishop to c5 before now kicking
the Bishop Bishop to e7
and now night-night B captures on d4
Knight to c6
now beaten now C 3 a 5 and B 5 Knight
captures C captures and Knights the B 6
+ alpha pushes a 4 and already this is
move 14 alpha is controlling 4 squares
on the sixth rank and this is this is
very nice
Knight to c4 going for the dark squared
bishop and here there are there are a
couple of moves you can choose from you
can decide to go for Bishop characters
night and c4 but it's the French defense
I also think that a light square bishop
is worth more than a dark square bishop
but then again you can go for something
like Bishop to c3 in getting the bishop
out of the way preserving the bishop
repairs and also protecting the d4 pawn
even even more but after a queen to c7
and group 2 c1 bishop to a3 would
attempt on the rook rook to a-1 Bishop
to b4 then a repetition is possible so
perhaps this is why alpha decide not to
go for this it actually had had a
brilliant idea after Knight to c4 it
played Bishop to d3 Knight captures on
b2 and here you can't capture with the
Queen if you capture with the Queen
Bishop to b4 you lose the Queen on the
other hand after knife capture son b2 if
you play Knight captures on b2 after
Bishop to b4 pinning the night you have
two castle and after Bishop to c3 your
rook is attacked and you're losing the
d4 pawn
so after Knight captures on D to alpha
zero had another idea kink captures on
e2 and this is this is great
Bishop to d7 was played and now the star
move of the game King to e3 and now the
King will be supporting this beautiful
central pawn chain and the King is
actually pretty safe only three this is
this is some maneuver by alpha b6 g 4 +
h5 we have Queen 2 G 1 H capture screen
captures and Bishop to f8 and again you
can see that all of black black spawns
are on light squares and alpha has a
pawn on a4 and b5 controlling his a a
5-point and b6 pawn and again this light
square bishop isn't really looking
looking good here we had h4 Queen to e7
rook H to C 1 alpha is now preparing to
double up on the C file g6 or up the C
to preparing row Casey
one King d8 rook AC one now and Queen to
e8 r up to c7 infiltrating blacks
position and rook to c8 offering to
exchange at least one pair one pair of
rooks rocket resin c8 with Czech Bishop
captures on c8 and now rook the c6
Bishop the b7 attacking the rook and
here rook to c2 was played why not
capture the pawn you might ask well if
you capture the pawn at king c7 and you
lose the rook okay you can play
something like rook to d6 and give up
the rook like this but after King
captures
Mike is up the exchange the pawns are
equal I mean five points on each side
but black has only to pawn islands White
has four pawn islands so it's definitely
favorable for black even though White's
pieces are a bit better placed but
Indian this should probably be better
for black but alpha doesn't go for this
Bishop rook to c2 was played King to d7
and Knight to g5 Bishop to e7 now
attacking the knight and here comes
another star move of the game stockfish
actually assesses this position as a
draw and offers the move Knight captures
on e6 followed by F captures on e6 and
after Bishop captures on g6 would
attempt on the Queen something like
Queen f8 + h5 and stockfish considers
this to be at the wrong position white
it does have compensation for the piece
but you know it doesn't seem like either
side can make progress but here alpha
has another idea alpha here plays Bishop
captures on g6 and what's the idea here
the idea is you can't capture the bishop
if you capture it you're getting made at
Queen captures on e6 with the Czech King
to d8 and now Queen captures on b6 with
check King to d7 and now e six this is
checkmate
so instead after Bishop captures on g6
Bishop captures and g5 was played Queen
captures on g5 and now F captures on g6
and now you might ask yourself selves
where's the compensation for the piece
what do I play now and here is office
idea
five and this is this is beautiful
what's the idea if you play he captures
on f5
this isn't good Queen to f6 and you're
in urine a lot of trouble
Queen to d6 there's a threat of Queen to
d6 checkmate and after Queen to f8
stopping this Queen captures on b6 now
Queen to be 8 and now not immediately
capturing the g6 pawn king to f3 first
now g5 h captures and g5 and after rook
checks using to play King to f4 now rock
to h4 check King captures on f5 and
after Queen to f8 check Queen to f6 and
you know you're winning this game Queen
captures he captures and these two
passed pawns are too powerful to stop so
after f5 what's the other plan if G
characters on f5 this is even worse
Queen to g7 with check and it doesn't
matter what you do if blinking the 8
went to c7 is checkmate and if you block
with for example Queen to e7 then you
can capture the rook this is perfectly
fine but even the barbaric rook to c7
check also wins the game can capture
screen captures and the King moves you
grab all the pawns this is winning so
after f5 stockfish decided to go for
rook to g8 now comes Queen 2h h 6 also
now threatening Queen to h7 check Queen
to f7 defending and now f6 now
completely locking in the position
creating a beautiful the past pawn that
is this f6 passed pawn and King to d8 by
stockfish king d2 now alpha creates a
path for the Queen to come to e3 and
then the c3 King to d7 rook to see one
pink the d8 stockfish doesn't really
have a move here a queen to e3 Queen to
f8 Queen to c3 and here stockfish plays
Queen to b4 and offers the exchange of
Queens the the threat is of course Queen
to c7 but playing something like Queen
to f7 results in King to e3 then after
Queen to d7
Queen to a3 and white
alpha will exchange Queens and v6 a king
to e8 Queen d6 now threatening rogue to
come to c7 and after Queen captures he
captures rook to f8 going for the F pawn
but now wrote to c7 and white is getting
rid of rid of this Bishop and then
picking up the Queen side pawns if you
try and stop this we drove to f7 rook
captures on f7 King captures and d7 and
there is no way to stop this pawn from
promoting the King can't get near it
because this one is covering 8 and this
point is covering east 7 so a very nice
idea
so after Queen to c3 stockfish decided
to go for Queen to b4 but now Queen
captures some b48 character some before
and rock to g1 threatening maybe a h5
but also preventing this rook from
moving because you know you can you
can't afford to lose the g6 pawn we have
b3 here King to c3 now alpha is alpha
decides to grab that pawn and transfer
the game to the Queen side even though
h5 is
h5 is most likely winning here but
obviously this is even better King to c3
Bishop to c8 this Bishop has no way of
entering the game which is us which is a
theme that repeats constantly in these
alpha 0 vs stockfish games King capture
some b3 Bishop to d7 and now came to be
for Bishop - eh and now up to a 1
preparing to push the pawns king to c7
a5 now Bishop to d7 a capture some b16
captures and rook to a6 check King b7
came to c5 now now the White King is
infiltrating into position rook to d8
now rook to a to rock to CH check King
d6
Bishop to v8 and now came to e7 this is
this is beautiful for white f7 is a move
that is that is prepared and here
stalkerish played g5 but it doesn't
really matter what it plays play
something like Bishop captures b5 then
you're getting f 7r up h8 and
now now you can play anything for
example Ruby do you paint the bishop
King has to defend and I mean you don't
even have to push the point to victory
you can simply slowly enjoy the position
and play King captures on e6
and then only then play King g7 + f8
Queen but after King e7 stockfish plate
to g5 Alfa captured H captures on g5 and
in this position now stockfish resigned
the game as there are no moves to be
played this Bishop still can't enter the
game evan g6 g7 is coming this is this
is simply too overwhelming so yeah I
really enjoyed this like I said I really
hate the French defence and I was very
happy to see how how alpha 0 demolishes
it and I hope those of you who played
the French also enjoyed this and also
those of you who play against the French
and I'm very interested what do you
think about el and masks artificial
intelligence accomplishment defeating
the professional dota 2 players and I
would like to thank Fernando s terrasse
de Oliveira and the Kilauea decima for a
contribution to my channel thank a lot -
really appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you all for watching
and I will see you soon perhaps with a
video from the London chess classic and
some human versus human games see you
soon